merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre nous proposons également la
suppression de cet article qui vise à
monétiser les rtt pour un certain nombre
visé des augmentations de salaire parce
que monsieur le rapporteur général vous
avez l'air nous dire que mais non mais
non vous êtes tout à fait favorable à
des augmentations de salaires il n'y a
qu'à en discuter dans les entreprises
mais nous avons quand même été un
certain nombre ici à défendre l'idée
qu'il fallait que le smic augmente et
avoir trouvé face à nous à une
opposition assez redoutable ce qui
n'aurait pas ce qui aurait donné un
signe une impulsion pour qu'on ouvre
précisément des négociations salariales
dans toutes les branches et aujourd'hui
non content de d'empêcher et de refuser
ces augmentations de salaires vous
utilisez la préoccupation fondamentale
du pouvoir d'achat des salariés pour
mettre des coins dans les 35 heures et
la réduction du temps de travail qui je
le rappelle au passage a quand même
permis de créer un nombre conséquent
d'emplois dans notre pays
je pense que de la même manière que le
dispositif
le dispositif concernant les heures
supplémentaires on vient d'évoquer le
travail du dimanche j'ai quand même une
petite inquiétude sur ce qu'on ressent
les uns et les autres de l'état d'esprit
du pays parce que là j'ai quand même
l'impression que c'est un grand concours
à qui ira le plus loin dans la
régression sociale
alors que les français demandent
finalement quelque chose d'assez
légitime c'est que quand tout augmente
dans le pays
quand les profits on en a beaucoup parlé
au début de cette séance augmente eh
bien il est légitime que les salaires
augmentent aussi sans régression sociale
parce que toutes les avancées de notre
pays ont précisément à portée du progrès
social et c'est ce sens-là duquel nous
ne voulons pas nous faire des tournées
pour ce qui me concerne et enfin ça va
concerner combien de personnes c'est la
mesure la ces 10% des salariés qui sont
je crois qu'on est loin de la réponse à
une trop longue l'occupant nazi chers
collègues mais site
[Musique]